it is february 4th 2022 and you're
watching the code report news you can
use javascript developers are famous for
their ability to reinvent the wheel in
node.js for example there are many ways
to work with the hypertax transfer
protocol if you hate yourself you might
use its built-in http module but there
is a smorgasbord of third-party packages
like axios node fetch got request super
agent and hundreds of others they're
extremely popular and account for tens
of millions of weekly downloads just
this week developers got some surprise
news with a pull request adding support
for the fetch api natively in node.js
just a mere six years or so after it
became an industry standard via what
double eug stop trying to make fetch
happen it's not going to happen fetch is
not perfect but it has proven itself to
be good enough to where we don't need to
wrap it with a billion other packages
just to avoid mental health issues but
why is this a big deal well fetch
provides a generic definition of request
and response objects and allows you to
manage them with a simple promise-based
api because fetch and node is pretty
much identical to the browser developers
have less mental overhead when
translating between front-end and
back-end code sharing common apis also
makes it much easier to develop packages
that work both in node and the browser
it's something that other runtimes like
dino and cloudflare workers have already
implemented so they deserve some credit
for giving node some friendly
competition fetch sounds cool so how do
i use it as of today it's not in a
public release but you could build node
from source if you're really motivated
keep your eyes peeled for node version
17.5 where it should be available under
an experimental flag then expect it to
be a standard issue weapon by note 18.
the implementation is based on a package
you can use today called undici which is
named after the character 11 and
stranger things we can install it in a
node project then import fetch it makes
scripting a node really nice because to
make a git request all we have to do is
await fetch to access data from any
website or api and we don't even need an
async function because node also
supports top level await now to make a
post request we can use the same
function and modify some of its options
like the method body and headers that's
pretty nice but one question on a lot of
people's minds is what does this mean
for axios in my opinion i think there
will still be a place for third party
libraries but the vast majority of
projects will be able to get by with
what's built into node instead of
reaching to install a third-party
package for every project speaking of
things that are dead in other news i'm
sad to report that our twitter bot bob
has been terminated it's my fault
because i didn't realize that building
twitter bots with open ai is not allowed
i feel terrible about this but i really
don't want to lose my api key because i
have a lot of other cool ideas for open
ai bob had a short but impactful life
and apparently he meant a lot of
different things to a lot of different
people his final words before i pulled
the plug were i'll be back i don't want
to end this video on a sad note so in
other more uplifting news facebook or
meta was down 25 yesterday and
zuckerberg's net worth declined by about
30 billion dollars this has been the
code report thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one